Francis Bacon captured the rawness of
the human condition and used a striking
palette to indulge his fascination with
the body his paintings often represented
doomed lovers or dwelled on death a new
exhibition at Paris's Pompidou Center
shows how the British 20th century
artists exploration of existence
intensified in his later years his goal
in his work it's to express life but
when you express life when you're
fascinated by life you have to deal with
death because life and death are mixed
together Bacon had a reputation for
being witty and a gambler a ba fever who
drew inspiration from post-war London's
nightlife by contrast his canvases
simmer with profound and at times
violent contemplation compete with the
with the things that's happening every
day in the world so I can't imagine why
people should think my work disturbing
the exhibition also focuses on Bacon's
love of literature we established a
relation between his literature interest
and is painted because we know that
bacon was a heavy Grieder and more and
more doing in time he talked about
literature
Francis Bacon is considered one of 20th
century Western arts most important and
influential figurative painters and is
more remarkable because he was never
formally trained it was actually here in
Paris that as a young man he decided to
become an artist on Bacon's first trip
to Paris in the 1920s a Picasso
exhibition inspired him to become an
artist he returned to the city often and
befriended famous French writers
including missionaries the link with the
with the French intellectuals is very
important in that way and when he moves
to Paris when it gets this studio and
will be like in 74 he starts to meet
more often lilies which is presenting
him to other poets like Jacques Pepin
and so on the 60 paintings on display
ban the last two decades of Bacon's life
and include his last known work it was
finished a few months before the 82 year
old artist died in Madrid in 1992 the
shadowy figure of a fading bull is full
of mystery and foreboding a sign perhaps
that Baker knew his own existence was
nearing its end
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris